hey web-slinger's is charlie so big news
Tom Holland is our new spider-man we're
gonna see him for like the next four
movies probably Avengers infinity war
two in case you have no idea what I'm
talking about Marvel just confirmed that
Tom Holland is gonna be the new
spider-man and then we'll go on to do a
new spider-man trilogy at Sony's
starting in 2017 if you have no idea who
Tom Holland is you've never seen him
before
Wolf Hall is like the the biggest thing
that he's done recently but he also he
actually just made a movie with Thor
which is kind of funny with Chris
Hemsworth it's called in the heart of
the sea it's not out till December so
you I mean you can't see it yet but you
can go see it later this year I just
think it's funny the way the Avengers
bump into each other when they're doing
other movies like Robert Downey jr. and
Mark Ruffalo doing zodiac way before
they ever did the Avengers together that
was actually Robert Downey jr. did that
movie before he became Iron Man the
director they picked for the first
spider-man film is also a relative
unknown his name is John watts he did
this movie called cop car that's gonna
be out in August it's not like a huge
studio blockbuster film or anything like
that Marvel just continuing the
tradition of raising new talent rather
than picking you know big stars right
now Sony's gonna have to live with these
people for like the next three
spider-man films you know that is unless
they pick a new director for the sequels
but Marvel deserves a lot of the credit
for picking these unknown actors and
directors there's a couple reasons they
do that one it's really expensive to
hire the biggest star and the biggest
directors on the planet so they find
someone new they have to pay him way
less the other big reason is is because
they're looking for a fresh voice like
when you hire Steven Spielberg to direct
all your movies you'll get a good movie
but it's gonna be his story every single
time that was one of the big criticisms
when JJ Abrams was picked to direct the
new Star Wars film it's like does JJ
Abrams get to re-envision the entire
sci-fi movie universe for the planet now
Marvel very wisely doesn't pick any one
person to do every single movie that
they do as much as these are big
franchise films and you can predict a
lot of what the plot is going to be each
new director brings something fresh to
the characters really the best example
of Marvel raising new talent is with
Robert Downey jr. and Iron Man he'd done
a whole bunch of stuff he had this huge
career behind him he was a child actor
but when they hired him
his career was on life support and he
was almost uninsurable studios can't
hire actors as they can't ensure them
behind the camera James Gunn is probably
like the best success story
he had a really solid track record with
his smaller movies but you know
guardians of the galaxy very different
story 150 million dollar Giants studio
film Marvel's real talent isn't finding
like really amazing talented creative
people and raising them up giving them
opportunities James Gunn even set you
know throughout the whole process of
making guardians of the galaxy mark
Marvel had this giant support system in
place but he was largely left to his own
devices to find the creative voice of
the film what Marvel does is they
provide the support system if you need
help with the writing or any of the
practical aspects of production anything
you feel like you need help with to get
the movie made they don't like Jam their
hands up directors butts and finger
puppet them around which might happen at
other Studios given that billions of
dollars are on the line I've already
done a couple spider-man Civil War
videos but the biggest question marked
this whole time is the actor that
they're gonna go with because that that
will largely inform what the character
is gonna look like all the best actors
are really open to the direction but I
feel like young actors actually learn a
lot more onset just because they don't
have the work history that older actors
do so even if you don't feel like Tom
Holland is is ready for like the crazy
action of an Avengers franchise Marvel
and Sony can train him to do that when
he's got the mask on they can totally
put a stunt person in there and just
have him do voice over ever since they
announced this Sony Marvel collaboration
with spider-man Kevin Feige has been
talking about his vision for the
spider-man character though he'll be the
most classic wisecracking quipping
version of the characters that you can
remember my mind since I'm a younger
person goes to Ben disses ultimate
spider-man run I would just read that
because it's a high school Peter Parker
that feels like a high school Peter
Parker spider-man is a superhero but for
the most part he's a kid in high school
so he's gonna experience a lot of
typical high schooler problems that's
really what's gonna set him apart from
these other Avengers characters I know
you guys are all probably wondering what
the dynamic is gonna be between him and
the other Avengers because there'll be
like almost too old to be considered his
Big Brother's most of the actors that
play the Avengers in real life you know
not including like Mark Ruffalo Robert
are in their early to mid-30s I mean
they're still pretty younger but they're
quite a bit older Robert Downey jr. is
almost old enough to be Tom Hollands
father so you can guess how they might
play on that idea in Captain America
Civil War in the comic books in comic
book Civil War spider-man is a little
bit closer to Tony Stark and aging in
Captain America so they're kind of like
big brothers the movie seems like it's
widening that gap so you have Captain
America dad versus Iron Man dad but for
the most part I'm not expecting
spider-man to have the same role in
civil war as he did in the comics
remember Marvel's job is to just
introduce the character and give you an
idea for what the tone is gonna be then
he'll go on to the Sony franchise where
that would that really develop him
really I feel like if you want to
compare Captain America Civil War to the
comics you have to think of the
spider-man role more as going to Black
Panther because that's Marvel's
character that they own 100% of
vibranium is now the most precious
resource in the Marvel Universe
so naturally Black Panther being the
person who controls access to that is
going to be a very important person to
the Avengers I mean think about it
Iron Man builds himself a new suit every
single movie why wouldn't the next one
be vibranium but for all intents and
purposes expect to see spider-man in a
you know a relatively minor but
important role in civil war I know there
was a lot of question about you know
which Marvel movie was he gonna show up
in first the idea is is that he would
show up in a Marvel movie first then go
on to the Sony franchise that means that
he has to be in a Marvel movie in 2016
Captain America Civil War is just the
most logical place to put him that's why
they were really down to the wire with
this casting choice there was still like
three or four actors on the list last
week they're about halfway done filming
Captain America Civil War so they're
gonna put him in the movie they had to
pick an actor fast picking an actor for
a franchise that big is like buying a
billion-dollar house you just hope you
made the right investment and all of you
are asking what changes they're making
from Civil War of the comic book that
was all about identity the superhero
Registration Act gun control Civil War
the movie is more about accountability
think about the collateral damage in
Avengers age of Ultron Ultron goes on a
rampage the hook ends up destroying half
of Johannesburg who is accountable for
that how did the Avengers fix that
Robert Downey jr. actually said
something interesting on his Facebook
page like in real life
he said he
felt like Tony Stark paid to repair all
that damage from the Hulk fight that
makes sense but but then think about it
inside the Marvel Universe you have all
the governments of the world looking at
the Avengers in what's going on
you know these massive stakes they'll
want to be able to hold the Avengers
accountable for what they do because as
much as they saved the world they also
destroy it
code GREEN was one of my favorite new
hulk things from hf ultron that was so
much fun
here's my big question for you guys how
do you feel about tom holland being
spider-man for the next 7 years remember
we have next year's Marvel movie then we
have three spider-man movies for the
next six years after that as weird as it
might feel for them to pick such a young
actor for Peter Parker think about it
this way
he's not gonna age out of the role by
the time they get to that third
spider-man movie he'll still be in his
20s but I'll probably do for my next
Marvel video is like my favorite
spider-man villains I just I haven't
done that many spider-man videos
recently and it now feels like a totally
appropriate time now that we have a new
spider-man and congratulations to this
week's giveaway winner I'm actually
gonna do my DC giveaway in this too just
in case I forget or it takes me too long
to get my DC video out this week kouno
in Ashton Bobby State you guys win $20
Amazon gift cards I'll remind you guys
again whenever I post my next flash
video that'll probably be like the next
video that I post be sure to private
message me on my channel so I can get
your guys contact info but I'll also be
doing you know flash and arrow videos
this week I know last week I didn't do
an arrow video now that we're kind of
like through the Game of Thrones
corridor I can I can ease off of that
and start doing some more comic book
stuff Comic Con is in a couple weeks so
I'll start doing some Comic Con preview
videos like next week maybe the week
after that so why you guys wait for all
that stuff to post in case you didn't
see it Darth Vader and ahsoka tano
we're on Star Wars rebels this past
weekend you can click here for my
breakdown of that episode it was badass
Darth Vader tore up for an entire
hour and you can click here to learn all
about resurrection in the game of
Thrones universe thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tomorrow
you